so the weekend just landed himself a new
gig the toronto-born artist
is developing a new drama series for hbo
and will serve as a co-writer and
executive producer while also
starring in the series it's currently
slated as
the idol the show will follow a female
pop singer who starts a romance with the
enigmatic la club owner
who is the leader of a secret cult so
weekend yes yes so the weekend is
teaming up
with sam levenson for the project who
previously created the hit series
euphoria
perfect pairing uh starting zendaya and
earned multiple emmy nominations for his
first
season this also isn't the weekend's
first rodeo here
last year he wrote and started an
episode of the animated series american
dad
also played himself in adam sandler's
uncut gems
yes well i mean i think we can just
agree that abel has proven himself just
in his own work and his music videos
he's an incredible performer he's an
incredible storyteller even before we
even knew his face we just listened to
his music his mixtapes and whatnot
he always was able to tell this story
and he tells it from such a perspective
that
um is is kind of dark and it's edgy
um but it's still very meaningful and it
always paints a very vivid picture it
makes sense for him to get into the
acting world at this length
to write and to be a part of it um i
find this interesting because sam
who is also the creator from euphoria
drake was the ep
for that so in my mind i feel like sam
is just going around
with all the toronto talent and being
like hey do you want to do a project
with me do you want to do a project with
me and rightfully so because we have a
lot of talent and right for yourself
100 rightfully so i think it's really
cool that he's been able to maintain his
aura
throughout like you said before we even
knew what his face looked like and just
knew his voice
the same aura all throughout these years
and even continuing into whatever this
next phase
is going to be clearly um has a lot of
vision
clearly like a creative powerhouse and
yeah the when you just read the
description
like you said it's just so the weekend
it just makes so much sense that this
would be the story that
they come up with together yeah you know
that it's just going to be so incredibly
dope and it says so much about the
weekend
just in how authentic he is as a human
being as a creative
and also how well he knows himself so
because for you to be consistent in
everything you do no matter what no
matter where you put him
he's going to be himself um and he's
going to make sure he
his work bleeds into everything that he
does and i just you know i just respect
him so much for this so i'm excited
this is going to be some edgy tv it can
be difficult for artists to make that
crossover then you take for granted how
difficult it is to do something else
when you've been
maybe categorized one way and you'll be
just talking about madonna madonna had
had done acting and directing but not
everything was taken very well
and the few things that we've seen uh
the weekend do
even if it's connected to his music or
outside his music performing in a
different way
it's been great like he's been
very good at anything he has done and
approached so
i have no doubt that this next thing is
going to be um good
and at least very very interesting yeah
oh it's going to be the best
i can't wait let's see so chat saying
here um
marina says he has such an unusual voice
as well
um wow what a perfect project for the
weekend to work on says julie
uh yeah paul says i love how keisha
refuses to call the weekend the weekend
it's able guys
i know i know i'm weird about stuff like
that i don't know it always weirds me
out but
that's funny no i just in terms of the
weekend's voice
very mj influenced with his own
edge and grit but yeah